voilà show dos à dos
on est contente oh oui on est contente
lauriane primes liées et éducatrices et
comportementaliste pour chiens c'est sa
quatrième séance avec olea berger
australien de dix mois
le problème de cette chaîne l'obéissance
de base
olea c'est bien fifi c'est bien au pied
c'est bien très bien
c'est une chaîne qui saute beaucoup d
calé dès qu'elle est malade et qu'elle a
envie de jouer dès qu'elle est contente
elle voilà c'est comme ça qu'est elle a
du mal à canaliser son énergie
l'objectif c'est de montrer qu'il ya des
temps de jeu mais aussi des temps voilà
où vous écouter à 32 ans est bruyant
courtoise a créé sa micro entreprise en
septembre 2010 huit conseils d'éducation
pour chiens compréhension du
comportement avec des exercices pour
faire comprendre l'obéissance à l'animal
souvent l'erreur qui est comme et c'est
quand on a un show on lui autorise tout
parce qu'il est petit sauf que il ne
faut pas oublier qu'un chiot s'agrandit
et que bah quand il est gros plus il a
été habitué à certaines choses et après
le retour en arrière est plus difficile
donc vaut mieux habitués à un show tout
de suite à certaines règles que plus
tard que je pense qu'en fonction du
caractère du chien en fonction de la
race on doit adapter aussi certaines
certaines choses moi moi même je
n'applique pas toujours la même chose
forcément en fonction des chiens j'ai
toujours une base mais ces variables ces
techniques lorien les a apprises lors de
sa reconversion professionnelle un
changement de voie et un changement de
vie choisi le métier que je fais enfin
en fait nous permet vraiment de
compléter et mon métier d'éducateur
canin et de m'occuper quand même une de
mes enfants qui va qui sont encore très
petit et ça me permet d'être partagé
beaucoup ma vie avec eux et partager
beaucoup de moments c'est des fiches
comme ça et je m'amuse et en fait à
reproduire ces fiches là après à les
résumés dans mon classeur les animaux
c'est une passion depuis son plus jeune
âge après le bac et deux ans de faculté
de droit
lauriane primo lire entre en école de
commerce après avoir obtenu son diplôme
elle intègre une agence de relations
presse basée à puteaux vraiment j'étais
contente mais sans plus voilà j'étais
c'est pas à cause fin pas forcément à
cause de l'argent ce pas forcément à
quoi j'ai du boulot en lui-même
c'était vraiment juste
je me suis dit je me vois pas faire ça
toute ma vie j'ai besoin de voir autre
chose de bouger d'être plus pas
confrontés à la nature chose que je
voulais faire et en plus jeunes avant
même que j'attaque tout mais grande
étude
ce côté-là communication marketing m'a
toujours intéressé et encore même
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que ça m'a un
petit temps ça me sert de base pour
créer mon site internet pour m'occuper
des réseaux sociaux de base de magma
société après avoir obtenu des
renseignements pour engager sa
reconversion
elle finance la formation a good and
park pour devenir éducateur canin et
comportementaliste des compétences
acquises entre le mois d'août 2010 est
et juin 2018 avec la possibilité de
s'occuper de ses enfants qui une partie
théorique qui se fait à la maison et
après un côté pratique donc une
formation pratique où on va dans le jura
et y est on bosse en fait les acquis
depuis le lancement de sa
micro-entreprise l'éducatrice canin
guyancourt toise a signé six contrats de
clients soit entre 6 et 8 rendez vous
par semaine